alors il ya une autre chanson qui
s'appelle côté jardins et côté cour
alors là ça dit il ya toujours le temps
qui courent et moi qui court après vous
oui mais ça a été vrai pendant longtemps
je suis obligé parfois de me rabattre
sur masi passé salies - aujourd'hui
évidemment ou du coup aurait pu après
aujourd'hui non non non il est
tranquille sur son lit regarde à moitié
à moitié ainsi remet enfin bon non
j'exagère
non non c'est plus d'actualité depuis
martigny
tant qu'il était là nous en raconter
tout ça tokyo 10 et on la connaît par
coeur mais absolument très intéressant
et elle est développée en long et en
large dans les livres de michel les
miennes absolument voilà vous dites que
jacques dutronc vous adresser la
solitude absolument absolument parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui pendant des années
étaient relativement absents même quand
il est là il a quelque chose d'un petit
peu absent alors je sais que certains
font d'un psychanalyse un peu cheap avec
ça mais bon ça y est ça c'est valable
quand même aussi un peu pour un père
absent marie accents soul et j'ai
toujours eu l'espoir de le voir plus
souvent et puis finalement un jour
jamais pris votre parti vous êtes dit
oui mais ces mêmes c'est même pas ça
quand je dis qui m'adresser à la
solitude sais c'est que j'ai été forcé à
assumer assurer une certaine solitude et
que finalement j'ai pris goût et que je
pense que si j'y ai pris goût
c'est parce qu'elle correspondait aussi
à ma nature profonde que je ne savais
pas au départ alors pour le menacer vous
lui disiez un jour tout ça mais ça me
fera ni chaud ni froid
1 et puis c'est arrivé je non mais c'est
pas ça c'est que quand le quand le temps
passe quand on connais quelqu'un depuis
très très longtemps les sentiments
évoluent c'est ce que tout le monde dit
et c'est la vérité donc c'est vrai qu'on
passe de de la passion avec tout ce que
ça implique de possessivité de jalousie
d'exclusivisme on passe de ça à une
amitié très particulière très
particulière et unique voilà jardiniers
bénévoles
ouais et vous dites aimer l'autre c'est
laisser vivre oui mais ça c'est quelque
chose que je peux dire aujourd'hui qu'on
pensait déjà quand j'étais beaucoup plus
jeune mais que je n'aurais pas été
capable de faire parce que quand on est
amoureux et qu'on est jeunes on a envie
d'avoir l'autre pour soi et on fait tout
pour l'avoir à soi et en même temps
qu'on fait tout pour l'avoir à soit on
fait exactement le contraire de ce qu'il
faut faire parce que évidemment ce qu'il
faut faire c'est le laisser le laisser
vivre le laisser libre et
effectivement dans cette chanson je dis
je parle d'envol quoi je parle d'ouvrir
les bras pour que l'autre prenne son
envol et non pas pour l'étouffer un
petit peu plus dans la prison dans
laquelle on aimerait être enfermé avec
lui alors ça n'empêche pas les aventures
il ya une chanson qui s'appelle sur quel
volcan voilà c'est une relation
clandestine dangereuse cacher oui c'est
un peu moi j'ai toujours été fasciné par
ça c'est pas vraiment d'actualité par
rapport à par rapport à moi et à ma vie
j'ai passé un petit peu le 4 par rapport
à ces choses là mais je sais pas
pourquoi ça me ça m'évoque le signe
parce que parfois je peux être inspiré
par des films ça m'évoque le très beau
fine de gila ce qui est important c'est
d'aimer
il ya une situation comme ça vous évoque
rien de personnel
non non non vous n'avez jamais eu une
aventure comme ça secret non pas gens
c'est en tout cas ce que j'étais à la
télé non en vrai c'est arrivé c'est qu'à
mon âge on perd la mémoire donc si c'est
arrivé j'ai oublié mais c'est un peu
dommage quand même c'est un peu dommage
qu dont les choses at pas avoir connu ça
je sais pas parce que je crois que des
situations comme ça c'est beaucoup de
souffrance pour tous - beaucoup de
soucis de ceux ci beaucoup de souffrance
un cc vous préférez pas avoir de soucis
qu'a voir aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui non quand j'étais plus
jeune ça m'est égal je concédais baisser
peu vers le danger commun